in the last year energy prices have
risen by 450
and they're only going to go up
in the last few months just look at
what's happened wow it's gone up so fast
actually the biggest increase we have
really ever seen there are five reasons
for this huge price hike a number of gas
platforms in the north sea have been
shut down for routine maintenance work
europe's stockpiles of gas are low after
a cold winter last year reserves weren't
built up again fast enough
russia has been sending less gas to
europe increasing demand and price
wind has been unusually slow in
september meaning the uk has had to fall
back on gas-fired power stations and on
wednesday the 15th of september one of
the two cables that brings in
electricity to the uk from france set on
fire
the national grid now says it won't be
back up to full capacity until spring so
if you're a household in the uk this is
likely to affect your energy bills
wholesale energy prices make up about 40
percent of a household energy bill and
it's those prices that are increasing
energy providers are allowed to pass on
those price increases to you meaning
your bills may sharply increase unless
you're protected by the government's
energy cap
the energy cap is a limit on the amount
that energy suppliers can charge per
kilowatt hour of gas and electricity
it's aimed at helping those least likely
to shop around for the cheapest tariff
such as elderly people that many
londoners are not going to be losing
universal credit 20 pounds a week and if
they on top of that
have to pay more expensive fuel bills
this winter i'm afraid some families
will be choosing between turning the
heating on or putting food on the table
four smaller energy companies have
already gone bust and many more are at
risk
that's because they haven't got enough
capital to cover the increasing prices
of energy before it's passed on to
consumers depending on how cold winter
is you could see a scenario where
actually we come out of winter with as
few as 10 or maybe even slightly less
suppliers coming into next year
if your energy company does go bust you
shouldn't be cut off your contract will
be passed on to a supplier of last
resort your energy bill may increase
when this happens
ask to be put onto their cheapest tariff
and then shop around you won't be
charged exit fees if you do choose to go
to a different provider
if you're on a fixed term contract
that's coming to an end you may struggle
to find an affordable replacement sky
news has heard reports of increases of
800 pounds a year for a fixed term
contract
it may be cheaper to have a variable
tariff until april because it means
you'll be covered by the government's
energy cap the price hikes are expected
to last for a while as winter makes
people use more energy but the prime
minister says we shouldn't be too
alarmed according to him this is all
just a result of the world getting back
to normal after covet you're seeing uh
you're seeing problems in the
in the supply chains uh very strong
demand for the gas around the world is
is producing this phenomenon but uh
we're going to fix it now this should be
a temporary problem and prices will calm
down once stockpiles are restored
supplies from overseas are returned and
the wind
picks up